m
[Musique]
trop
bon je vous emmène tout de suite là sur
le stand de tester l on est au c est
pour vous montrer un produit je trouve
intéressant alors c'est pas une grande
révolution ce n'est pas un produit tout
nouveau on repasse dire c'est un truc de
fou non c'est ce produit leur caisse qui
raconte ce produit le chicago va en fait
il reprend un form factor qu'on connaît
déjà c'est un smartphone de samsung le
galaxy z flipper z philippe 3
c'est-à-dire un smartphone qui se prend
comme ça qui est sourd et vous avez un
écran à l'intérieur c'est exactement le
même facteur euro pourrait se dire quel
est l'intérêt de vient présenter ça il
ya plus de choses à savoir déjà ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que tu es si elle
fabrique des produits finis bien
évidemment que ça des smartphones des
télés et compagnie mais tcl fabrique
également des écrans et ça c'est
intéressant ici vous montre
effectivement le tour de force d'arriver
sur technologie du pjak tout le monde là
dessus il ya au nord qui va présenter un
smartphone pliable d'ici quelques temps
que ses angles est en tout cas un peu
plus grand donc le pliable évolué on
vote des grandes marques comme tcl s'y
mettent en termes de produits finis par
ce qu'il fabrique déjà des écrans qui
l'on devrait savoir faire et une vraie
maîtrise nature et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils ne prennent pas
part l'idée du z faut observer ce très
grand smartphone qui s'ouvre pour faire
comme une espèce de grosse tablette non
ils le pren dans l'idée de la
miniaturisation dans l'idée de la
réduction avec ce smartphone le chicago
alors chicago pour l'instant c'est juste
un prototype c'est pas un produit fini
alors là oui effectivement il est fini
on voit mais c'est un proto il n'a pas
vocation à sortir tout de suite en tout
cas parce qu'il cherche à réduire les
coûts et à vous proposer des smartphones
à des coûts réduits leur ai posé la
question et m'ont dit si ce smartphone
devait sortir aujourd'hui il sera plus
de 1000 euros 1000 $ ou en dollars on
aux us mais c'est pas le but en tout cas
cherche vraiment à réduire les coûts
pour proposer un smartphone pillage à
petit prix donc pour l'instant ce
chicago et bien on voit qu'il est là on
voit qu'il est intéressant on voit qu'il
est joli mais il va pas arriver tout de
suite mais ce qu'on voit et ce qui est
intéressant c'est l'évolution du
smartphone qu'explique mais surtout le
choix du form factor on part du plus
grand on le réduit et c'est pas mal
[Musique]
alors regardez à quoi ça ressemble déjà
donc vous avez votre smartphone qui est
comme ça vous le prenez vous l'ouvrez
alors moi il est attaché pour pas être
volé c'est un peu dommage que ça le rend
moche parce qu'un seul principe je
trouve très très joli c'est vraiment le
même facteur qu'on a sur le galaxy 7
flip ici il n'y a absolument pas de jour
il ya un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales situé sur la tranche bouton
volume de l'autre côté on n'a absolument
rien revient de recharge est ici en usb
sais mais bon là pour l'instant il ya
l'alarme-eau calais positionner là le
tiroir de cartes sim de l'autre côté ben
rien il n'y a pas d'inscription ses
jambes sur le dessous on voit pas grand
chose forcément parce qu'il ya leurs
énormes alarme qui vient un peu planqué
tout ça et qui est pas très très très
joli on va retrouver sur le devant ici
une double caméra ça c'est intéressant
donc j'ai pas les specs j'ai pas d'infos
je sais juste que j'ai une caméra de 44
mégapixels mais je ne sais pas si c'est
celle là non je crois que c'est celle
peut-être qu'il ya à l'intérieur parce
que lorsque vous l'ouvrez bien
évidemment dans vous allez avoir une
caméra et planck est juste là mais 100
dinars et aux instants et ce qui nous
intéresse vachement et bien c'est
l'écran ici il ya un choix qui est
différent par rapport à samsung vous
venez vous déplacer comme ça pouvait
activer je pense la caméra voilà donc là
j'ai un tout petit retour moniteur c'est
pas dingue mais bon voilà c'est ça la et
je vais avoir la météo la musique qu'est
ce que je vais retrouver mon a forcément
la date du jour comme on est sur un
photo il encore des petits bugs mais bon
voilà il n'ya pas de musique pour
l'instant je sois il va que sané
paramètres ici donc c'est vraiment un
petit écran de notification et rien de
grïngo mais bon il a intégré comme ça je
crois c'est joli c'est parce que vous en
pensez mais bien vite le mois en
commentaire est ce que vous aimez ça est
ce que vous trouvez ça c'est réussi
sympa ou alors pas du tout et lorsque
vous l'ouvrez pas forcément on va
retrouver un grand écran leur diagonale
salut 6,67 poussée du foulage idée et
puis on peut l'utiliser comme on le
souhaite comme explique tout ça plutôt
bien j'ai pas la même sensation c'est
marrant que sur le z philippe ça c'est
cool par contre 1 voyez je ne sens pas
la pliure sous le doigt ah si l'aja sans
un petit peu mais je la sens un petit
peu moins que sur le z flip ça c'est pas
mal pour le coup c'est assez malin de la
part de tcl il ya une vraie différence
de conception quand même regarder je
vous emmène sur le stand de samsung là
vous avez le galaxy des deux flics 3
c'est exactement la même chose au terme
du form factor ce qui va changer c'est
l'écran qui là est beaucoup plus grand
et beaucoup mieux intégré je trouve mais
sinon le form factor c'est même alors la
différence qu'on va retrouver également
c'est sur le smartphone de samsung vous
avez l'écart une ouverture en fait bref
les deux parties ne touche pas alors que
son modèle de test et alice touche mais
sinon dans l'idée c'est le même form
factor c'est en tout cas le même
principe alors forcément tout en anglais
ici encore quelques paramètres qui sont
vraiment dédié tcl voir le nxt les
jeunes qui est un petit moteur en fait
nous permet d'améliorer l'image mais ça
on en avait déjà parlé quand on avait
déjà parlé d'un 3d d'un smartphone aux
tcl il ya quelques temps à l'intérieur
c'est un écran amoled va forcément
d'essayer maîtrise des écrans amoled son
ultra ce que je retiens c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'effectivement ils
défendent factor je le connais déjà tout
ça tourne sur un qualcomm sa dragonne
ses 1 765 j'ai ici on a six giga de ram
et 128 giga de stockage il y en a une
batterie de 3545 milliampères alors donc
j'ai pas plus d'informations à vous
donner c'est en tout cas intéressant de
voir que tester elle vient développer ce
format là comme sur le smartphone de
samsung allait vous avez l'adaptation
lorsque vous leur fermer comme ça donc
ça c'est pas mal et je vois que je peux
venir activé mon écran avant garde et
comme ça pour avoir un preview donc
lorsque je devais refaire une photo et
danse peut venir me voir comme ça ok sur
le principe pourquoi pas je trouve moins
cool à l'avant que celui de samsung j'ai
l'impression qu'il est plus grands
renforts de vraiment les avoirs côte à
côte pour sa rencontre mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est un peu plus petit
donc là je peux venir désactivé à garder
j'active et désactive mon écran avant
pour que la personne que je prends en
photo puisse voir ou même moi si je le
souhaite et un zoom j'ai un ultra
grand-angle cas vous regardez un peu ce
créateur de mois x 2 jusqu en faut dix
on s'en doutera à la fois dit c'est
vraiment pas ouf jusqu'à foix ii on peut
faire des trucs quoi j'ai différents
modes portrait propane au bon sens c'est
un très très grand standard ya rien de
bien des cônes en plus ma caméra de
celle fille qui est juste là où coup
c'est moi donc kad merad selphy qui est
planqué juste là et des petits bugs mais
bon tout cas ça c'est rigolo donc voilà
pour ce prototype si les tcl c'est le
chicago elle reste que le chicago
arrivera un jour jusqu'à paris jusqu'à
lyon clermont ferrand marseille grenoble
je ne sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est que
eh bien on voit que c'est l'évolution
des smartphones qui explique l'évolution
et le choix surtout qu'ils ont fait ici
avec ce form factor qui est tout
particulier tout mignon que j'aime
beaucoup qui trouve vraiment intéressant
et vous savez tous les retours que j'ai
eus notamment au niveau de samsung sur
le sel filtrant les est folle de 3 bien
tout le monde préfère entoure le
explique 3 le smartphone qui rétrécit en
tout cas ma femme l'adopter elle aime
beaucoup est-ce qu'elle aimerait chicago
j'en sais rien à ce que justin kamgue de
chicago 10 le royaume mais moi tout ça
c'est rigolo donc voilà à voir si un
jour tcl nous le sort à quel prix si
nous le sortent à 700 euros 600 euros ça
serait juste hyper canon on suivra ça
bien évidemment où j'avais très bien
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
surtout à me dire ce que vous en pensez
ce qui peut vous tentez où ils n'ont
quoi comment vous marquez bien
évidemment tout ça en bas ont commenté
adam se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech et ça c'est cool
parce qu'il ya plein de choses au csa
sera aussi un tour des trucs cool du crs
des trucs un peu moins cool pascal
coville je vous donnais un peu les
coulisses nous montre un peu comment ça
se passe vous dire qu'avec gars sait pas
où c'est calme ya plein de choses cool
mais c'est plus calme c'est comme ça
allez vous embrasse à l'entretien
[Musique]